Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to The Joy of Creation.
This time...
We've...
G- No..?
Hang on!
No, Foxy!
No! Get out of here!
We've had enough of you, Foxy.
We've got...
Chica involved.
So, welcome to the party, Chica.
And I actually tried to record this a little bit ago,
But unfortunately,
Chica, my dog, was in the room.
And every time I said the word "Chica,"
she came running over and interrupting my recording.
So she's down in her Play Pen right now.
Sooo...
Let's get started...
Hi Chica!
How ya doing?
Welcome to the party...
Now the whole gang is here.
-and yes, i HAVE seen the new sister location trailer
It looks very good.
A--And first of all!
(...)
Fuck that 'dancy pants' character.
The one--the ballet dancer.
Y'know. that's..
I'm not..
Auhh- Of all those.
I mean, I know Baby is doing fine.
"Collect 10 drawings within 3 minutes."
But if you haven't seen the trailer, go see it definitely.
It's, It's worth watching.
What the..?
What?
What the-? What the hell??
Why-
I can only move the mouse when I'm...
AHHH!! FUCK!
*Markiplier.exe has stopped working, press any button to reboot...*
Ahh..
Ahhhhh, no!
For some reason..
I--I can only, I can only move it when I'm holding it down.
So...
"Collect 10 drawings within 3 minutes."
Ugh.
Where? Where and why?
Where and why?
I don't even see Chica.
Okay.
EAAHHHHH!
I don't understand the mechanics of you!
Alright.
Lighted road.
That makes me feel nice and safe. (You think?)
Ugh!
So how did Chica come runnin' up and killin' me?
How'd that happen?
I don't--uhhh.
(Mark turns into a seal)
oh--AH!
WHAT THE FUCK!?!
AHHHHHHH!
aaaahhh...
What the hell happened!?
What the hell was that!?
Was it because I was looking at her?
Ohh man!..
Ohhh baby!..
OHHH MAN!!
Okay..
So don't look at her is the.. the secret of success here.
Also I guess don't stand still because that's seemed to be what killed me before.
Man, this is definitely if the other games didn't give me a Slenderman vibe,
this one's definitely pumpin' it up considering I'm walkin' through the woods...
literally collecting notes off of trees.
If there's a big red silo dildo in the distance, I'm gonna be VERY upset.
Eh.
Where's she at?
Oh boy.
Well this is, um, this is, um, this is a different experience, huh?
I guess I could try running.
That'd be nice, huh?
I've got a--oh it's-- (BEHIND YOU!)
AHHH! FUCKING-!
Ahhhhhhhhhh!
W H Y?
AH! I KEEP TRYING TO REACH BEHIND ME, IT KEEPS COMING UP BEHIND ME!
WHY?!!!
WHAT DID I DO?!
WHAT DID I DO!?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I DID! I TRIED TO LIVE A GOOD LIFE!
I tried to be friendly! Wow, that, that branch is just doing the wibbly dance.
Okay.
So.
Ah! AH! AHHHHH! AHHHHHHH!!
(Chica shrieks)
AHHHHHH.....
I don't know.
I don't know, I don't know what she wants from me.
(Sobbing) I don't know how to beat this.
I don't know how to do this!
(sniff)
I don't know what it wants!
Oh man!
Ohhhh! Man!
Uh.
Oh.
Death is gonna lurk.
See, the thing is...
AH! FUCK! (Chica comes out of nowhere again)
I'm okay.
It's alright.
It's okay.
It's only death that comes...
due to constraints that I can't seem to control...
in events that are beyond my power to wield.
What the fuck is going onnnnn???
Let me try walking no flashlight.
How 'bout that?
Maybe that will help.
A little--
AH!
AH! FUCK YOU!
WHAT THE FUCK DO I DO?!!?!
(Crying)
I don't have a goddamn clue of what I'm supposed to do.
I don't know how to beat this.
I have a funny feeling...
that when...
Chica comes a runnin'...
there ain't nothin to be done.
I'm just gonna, I'm gonna tuck my head between my knees and kiss my ass goodbye.
AH!
(Screech)
Oh, man, maybe if I compliment her on her style, her impeccable style, SHE'LL LEAVE ME ALONE!
(Mark as a caveman grunt)
Oh.
Uh oh.
UH OH, UH OH
OH SHIT!
OH SHIT!!
Alright, I'm begining to think I got a pranked version.
And it's literally just uncontrollable death at random intervals.
And there's not a damn thing I can do. D:
OH! BOY!
HOORAY ME!
(Girly scream)
Does it want me to, like, take my time?
*Awkward silence*
AHHH! Whoa! Oh, hello!
(What are you doing?! RUN!)
(I think you should get the premise of it now.)
Why did--why did she stop?
Why she'd stop?
What- What made her stop?
I, I dunno, but that was different though.
At least something happened, okay.
I looked at her and she went away but then I-I stared too long maybe?
Hm...
Oh!
Whoa shit!
(content intensifies)
Okay.
Okay. Oh, okay.
OKAY!
Ugh.
UGH!
UGHHHH!
AH!
AHH! I DON'T KNOW WHAT I DID!
BUT I WAS DOING SOMETHING!!!
Huh?
AH! FUCK ME!!
(RAGEIPLIER)
Ah, man, that'll be FUCKING IMPOSSIBLE!
HOW ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO DO THAT?????
Especially considering you spawn in at random points around the map!
Well, I mean not random but like a few established points.
How am I supposed to get my bearings?
Man!
I don't get it, maybe I am supposed to turn it off and then walk away? I don't know.
She's behind me.
(O_O)
(>_<)
(;;:☉д☉)
WHOA!
WHOA!!
WHOA!!!
WHOA!!!!
HEY!
FUUUUUUUUUUUUCK! FUCKING FUCK!
WHAT DO I DO? D:
(crying) I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO!
Uh I don't get it, man.
She'll, like, pause for a second...
...but just a second.
And if you do it too long, she hates your guts.
Oh man, I'll give it one more try, but I don't know.
Man.
Oh man.
This is rough.
(Chica's mad already) Whoa.
OH SHIT.
What in the--I didn't know you were there.
I didn't know.
Maybe she really do. I have a funny feeling she does not like the flashlight is my main guess...
That's why there are actual points of illumination around the map with the lampposts.
Those are like giving you reference to where you are and giving a little bit of light.
(Very focused Markimoo)
'cause my instinct is...
She doesn't know where I am right away 'cause otherwise she'd be making a beeline for me.
So, she kind of wanders around and then stumbles across me.
And then closes in for the kill once she spots me.
Because after a while she doesn't really...
Oh shit.
WELL, FUCK THAT IDEA!
AHHHH!!!!
WELL SHE DOESN'T LIKE RUNNIN' EITHER! SHE DOESN'T LIKE RUNNING!
SHE DOESN'T LIKE YOU LOOKING AT HER!
SHE DOESN'T LIKE YOU USING YOUR FLASHLIGHT!
SHE DOESN'T LIKE YOU RUNNING (You said that already.)
-_-
Fuck! What a needy girl!
WHAT A NEEDY
WHAT A NEEDY NEEDY
WHAT A NEEDY NEEDY NEEDY!
CHICA'S SO NEEDY!
AH! SHIT.
FUCK.
Okay I can't, I can't do it, I--I don't know..
I DON'T KNOW!
I DON'T KNOW!!
Maybe you're supposed to like line of sight her...
...with a...
TREE?!
It's the only other thing I can possibly think of.
Like maybe?
Fuck. I've reached the edge of the map without finding another goddamn page!
Oh boy... (How many times have you said that?)
THERE'S ONE MORE!
GOOD!
AH! FUCK!
AH! FUCK! AH! FUCK!
AH! FUCK! AH! FUCK! AH! FUCK!
AH! FUCK! AH! FUCK! AH! FUCK! FUCK!!
AH! FUCK! AH! FUCK! AH! FUCK! FUCK!! FUCK!!!
AH! FUCK! AH! FUCK! AH! FUCK! FUCK!! FUCK!!! FUCK!!!! F U C K!
🦆 QUACK! 🦆
AHHHHH!
Ahh ok, alright I can't do it.
This is for more intrepid souls than I!
This is for more, persistent douchebags than I am. And I'm a pretty persistent douchebag!
So let's just say goodbye by running in a
circle really quickly.
Okay. So I have a theory about Chica.
This is what I think her behavior is.
You get away from her in the dark.
She's very light based.
She only seems to run up to me when I'm near sources of light.
So if I say, for example, in running around in the DARK...
...she's not gonna bother me 'cause she
doesn't know where I am. But she can hear you.
You still can't stare at her, that's the number one rule you cannot stare at the Chica.
Number one first and foremost, can't do it. But, the only problem is the only way to get her to...
...stop from killing you if she's on your tail
is to glance at her.
So it's like this weird "catch 22" system, where you can't look at her but there's also no gauge to know...
...how soon she is until you've had--she's had enough of you glaring at her.
So right here, you see she's right there.
But...
...if I say...
...yeah. See?
I can get away from her...
...a little bit, not a hundred percent but you can get away from her.
Nevermind. Theory broken. (LOL)
Whoa! Fuck!
Okay that didn't matter.
Fuck. I don't know.
I, I have no idea, um... theory broken! It didn't work. So, I AM DONE!
I can't do it!
If i had hours and hours and hours then maybe, maybe I could do it, but I don't have
hours and hours and hours I just have the time that I have now so I will leave it up to-
-you guys to figure out the best way to
beat this if you can let me know 'cause holy shit this is difficult.
So thank you everybody so much watching!
Let me know if you beat it down in the comments below, and give me strategies for how to do it for myself.
Because the developer did say
that if you beat all of them...
...you get a little Easter egg or surprise or secret or something like that. (SOUNDS LIKE FUN!)
So thank you again! And as always I will see you, in the next video
BUH-BYE!
(Shirked- haunted plays)
(Subtitles edited by Zi Wang)
(Subscribe to Mark and check out more of his amazing content!)